he has achieved what many had once
written off as impossible with no party
no political apparatus just a grassroots
movement Emmanuel macron has defied
convention his supporters at their Paris
party were ecstatic their man
centrist pro-europe progressive is now
close to becoming the next french
president just width dr. drew in two
weeks time I hope to become your
president look 50 dot the president of
all the French people the president the
president of Patriots faced was a threat
of nationalist 100 miles to the north in
her Rust Belt stronghold the woman to
stop him
marine lepen has defied her critics to
those who said the lepen brand of
far-right anti-eu politics could never
become mainstream they were wrong she
addressed her faithful Boyd in the
knowledge that she'd achieved the best
results in the history of the front
Nationale but her message was for those
whose vote she now needs tell us and
I've been a fool appropriate I'd like to
launch an appeal to all the sincere
Patriots wherever they come from
whatever their origins are whatever
their journey in life and whoever they
voted for in the first round to join me
I'm calling on them to put aside old
fights and misunderstandings because you
need to put the needs of the country
first that's what's important what's
truly essential what's at stake is the
survival of France
among those celebrating we found teacher
Evelyn Poe a and her daughter normally
they happy on that no marine is
absolutely not racist she doesn't want
to deport people it's just those that
are in France illegally and those
fundamentally terrorists there you go
then there are foreigners who have
worked for years in France they want to
stay in France well that's fine it turns
out most poles were spot-on in
predicting a macron lepen runoff but her
task is now huge the same polls suggest
a victory for macron in a fortnight
there'll be a lot of champagne drunk
here tonight the reality though is that
this result is not really a surprise the
big big challenge for marine lepen and
all her supporters is the next two weeks
because back in Paris the losers were
lining up to back her rival not all that
long ago conservative Francois fior had
this election in the bag
then came the corruption scandal
surrounding his wife state money and
fake jobs without that he may well have
beaten lepen now he's telling his
supporters not to turn to the right and
back her but to the left and macro Julis
ooh I can assure you that extremism can
only give rise to misfortune and
division within France and so therefore
there's absolutely no other choice than
to vote against the extreme right so I
will vote in favor of Emmanuel macron
far left Canada Jean Luc mellon shop may
have come forth but for someone as
radical as he is that quite some result
he refused to endorse either lepen or
mackerel supporters a marine lepen
partied late into the night they know
that this first round marks a new era in
French politics
neither mainstream party has made it
into the second round that's never
happened before
the winner in two weeks will determine
the direction of France and of Europe
Mark Stone Sky News in France
you